i think uh i think almost all of it is a
fad if you there there's a very small
minority of people who even apart from
any fad and any of this being suggested
to them would have some
confusion some delusions about their
true identity and if you want to know
what percentage that would be we'll just
look at the generations before any of
this was promoted or suggested or
advertised and if you go back to like
our grandparents generation it's like
point something percent that would have
identified as trans
that's the number that's the number of
people who
have the mental
condition and and the rest of this is
societal i mean interrupt but just to
say because i'm sure a lot of you
receive that counter argument well
they'll say oh no but they weren't
comfortable coming out back then so the
environment is different i'm sorry to
interject but i'm sure a lot of you have
heard that argument how do we respond to
that well what do they always say they
say that um if you don't affirm
somebody is trans
then they're going to kill themselves
you're creating suicide right we've
heard that a million times okay well
hold on a second
so back in 1950 let's say there's point
zero one percent identifying as trans
but in reality there's like ten percent
trans and they're but they're not being
affirmed was there an epidemic of people
killing themselves in 1950 because they
weren't being affirmed as trans did that
happen like at all
ever so so it that's my response it just
the whole theory breaks down according
to them if that's true that in 1950 they
were 10 trans but they weren't being
affirmed then there should have been a
mass suicide epidemic that didn't happen
the mass suicide epidemic is now
the mass suicide epidemic is alongside
the affirmation
that's that's what's causing the suicide
so it's the exact opposite of what
they're saying and so
a lot of people so this is an
interesting component i think this is a
good way to end this which is what do we
actually do about it so i think the
frustration that people have about this
issue is that 99 of america does not
believe men can become pregnant
maybe less 90 i don't know 99 of america
think this stuff is insane all the while
99 of america is afraid to talk about it
which is that
there's an incredible
we mentioned at the beginning there's a
bullying a harassment intimidation a
threat and a fear around this issue so
matt give us a status report who's
winning are the is the alphabet mafia
winning is it you know the cartel of
chemical castration are we starting to
gain some ground do you see some promise
are you more optimistic
give us your report uh they are winning
right now we have the statistics we
talked about the numbers it's clear that
right now they're winning
but this is one i'm not usually
optimistic on anything so if i'm
optimistic on something then it's
there's reason to listen i am actually
optimistic on this i think that
we're not winning right now but we can
win okay gender
ideology is pervasive ubiquitous uh
incredibly toxic and harmful and
dangerous and it's beatable we can
easily beat it and i discovered this
myself filming this documentary because
all i did i went around and i just asked
the simplest most basic questions and
what i discovered is that this is an
ideology that is so weak so flimsy so
utterly hollow at its core that it
cannot withstand the pressure of even
one
genuine question asked with real
skepticism all you have to do is just
stand up straight
look this confront this thing look at
straight in the eyes and ask it
questions
demand that it explain itself okay if
you're going to come to me with this
gender ideology thing explain it tell me
why i should accept it answer these
questions and they can't do it they just
fall apart so we we can win but we have
to have if we're not willing to actually
stand up and ask the questions then
we're not i mean we'll require some
a little bit of courage